mgm resorts says it is making meaningful  progress as it bounces back from the  covid pandemic president and ceo bill  hornbuckle  was on a call with investors in talking  about pent-up demand  causing business to really accelerate in  mid-february  on the first of may they will reopen  nightclubs in distancing at pools  down to three feet hornbuckle says they  are now  also hiring the first three weeks  that this thing really took off in the  middle of march we got caught off guard  if you ask this today we probably have  thirteen hundred openings  if you asked us in the middle of  nineteen how many openings we have in  any given moment  it's about thirteen hundred again  thirteen hundred job  openings hornbuckle expects the comeback  to speed up over the next 60 days  they estimate 90 percent occupancy by  early 2022